Hey, what's going on? His Bill Burr.
And it's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
June 20th,
2016 what's going on?
How are you, how are
you doing? You Collins?
Um, she noticed sounds a little weird. Uh,
I'm in a hotel in Baltimore, Baltimore,
Baltimore.
Um,
I can't say that because I've watched
Scarface so many fucking times.
I can't watch, I can't say Baltimore
without picture and fucking, you know,
Tony Month is that fucking
ac coming back on again.
How many fucking times I got to
hit off. Ah, Jesus fucking Christ
is a fucking button on here. Literally
just says off off. There we go off.
Shut off. Please shut off.
Thank you. Fuck Sakes.
I'm sorry. Um, anyways,
so believe it or not,
I'm doing this because I'm flying back
to La as you're listening to this and I'm
so sad to say, I haven't watched
the fucking NBA finals yet,
but, um, I do promise you if Cleveland
wins that I will do something. Uh,
I got to do something special as
something. Um, because WHO's kitten? Oh,
the warriors already want it,
right? If they repeat, fuck. Sorry,
I held it too closely. If they repeat,
then it's going to be like, all right,
can they three pizza next year?
I feel like is their big thing so that
they can go down with all the teams that
have won three in a row. So this year
is sorta like, you know, you know,
it's not as exciting. I'm sure
warrior fans who I don't give a fuck.
I'd love to see Lebron do it.
You know,
after everybody gave him
shit for the way he left,
which they should have because like I
said, he gave everybody fucking, you know,
sports blue balls. Like maybe
I'll go here, maybe I'll go there.
Who wants to buy me a drink?
Yeah,
he was being very conty and then he
went to fucking Miami. Jesus Christ.
What the fuck happened to her? I got
have the TV not on in the background.
Okay,
good Lord. Getting old as the
worst. I just saw some woman,
she had her fucking head.
Do you ever see like when a dog
gets confused and cocks her head,
like your head was just like that? Um,
what is that called? What is that from?
How do you avoid that as if fucking
alternate neca exercises you can do on the
other side of your fucking head.
So that doesn't happen to you.
Okay.
It's so fucking weird. Why? Why
can't you just like, you know,
why can't death just be like the old
right there for it? You don't, I mean,
why does it have to be just like this
slow fucking descension into like God
knows what the older I get,
the more frightening that
is. When you were younger,
you just like, Jesus, that old
fuck what happened to them and me,
I'm looking at it now go like, you know,
in the next 20 fucking years, you know,
I better start eating better.
Jesus Christ.
I'm off the rails and my fucking day.
Does anything make you feel fatter than
eating room service in your bed in a
fucking hope.
Just eating and yet in a bed in general,
not that makes you feel fatter
than eating in a bed. You know,
just fucking sitting there getting crumbs
and your sheets and shit and you're
trying to scrape it off onto the floor.
You just feel like a fucking animal.
You like laying on you. I was like,
literally on my side. I'm in Maryland,
so I get some sort of crab cake sandwich.
Of course it's sucked because I got to
the hotel instead of the spot to get it
at right. And I'm on my fucking
side and I'm eating the fries.
I'm literally sitting there like
that fucking lifeguard, you know,
when he got shit faced and he was eating
the burger and everybody laughed at him.
Hasselhoff, everybody was laughing at
him. Like it was fucking nuts to me.
It's like, like, dude, you never did that.
You never just been laying on your full
floor, hammered eating a fucking burger.
You should try it.
Sometimes the food is delicious.
It takes it to a whole other level.
You're so fucking psyched
and so appreciative of the
God damn food, you know,
if he want. So I advocate everybody doing
that this week. Get fucking hammered.
Order a burger,
lay on your floor.
Just start talking shit in
honor of father's Day while
your daughter films you.
And I think that's, I think
that's the way to go. Um,
people already texted me, you
watch the game anyway, tonight.
Now I'm fucking working. Actually somebody
tweeted at me going, what the f what?
What's with your agent? Why to,
how would your agent book a show?
You know, when this game seven of
the NBA finals, it's like, hey,
stupid. Like it's not like
we booked it after game six,
six been on the books for months. We
had no fucking idea. I didn't know.
So, um, anyways, uh,
I really want to see a, I love the
warriors man, by the way. You know,
I have no beef with those guys,
but it's just as a sports fan when,
I don't know if the dog in the fight,
it would just be great to see the Brown
after all the Shitty God and all those
sad sack Cleveland fans burned his
Jersey standing there and they're fucking
cargo shorts, right? Burden the Jersey.
What people filmed it so fucking stupid.
That is so stupid.
And I'm not singling out
Cleveland Cavalier fans,
but when people just take
sports to that level,
like when Lane Kiffin left
fucking Tennessee and there
was that one guy going,
let me tell you something,
you fucking piece of shit and link care
for and you're going to fucking leave
here. You're going to leave
here. Like Tana sees it. Uh, uh,
we ain't no stepping stone to USC.
We were booking,
we were fucking destination skill.
This is what I think book
and lean bird can key up and,
and I don't know what he had.
He had some lane Kiffin something or
like a program and he fucking peed on it.
A grown man filmed themselves paying
on that program. It's like toad.
Someday you're going to have kids.
The fuck is wrong with you. Well,
I'll give birth by a fucking kid.
It,
I'm right there at their little
dicks out paying right with me.
I don't take it to that
fucking level or whatever.
So I always thought it was stupid.
You know,
this is something like
really like medieval about
like is it looks like you're
at a book burning or something when
you sit in there burning a jersey,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
is Jesus is going to come down
the street with this cross neck?
Next thing he'd start yelling,
crucify him. It's, you know,
at the end of the fucking day,
who you know, who gives a shit?
If you at the fucking options,
Cleveland fans, all right?
Of staying and miserable downtown
Cleveland with all those miserable fucking
fans are going to Miami beach with some
of the hottest fucking ass that has ever
been fucking grace the earth.
You know?
Beautiful fucking weather, right?
You buy a hurricane proof house.
I don't know what the
fuck that looks like,
but God knows if anybody had the money,
it'd be a fucking professional athlete,
you know? Of course you would go
down there. You want a couple, two,
three. What? He went three down there,
I four or five [inaudible] six finals in
a row and he'd come back to Cleveland.
All right,
you fucking Snowden conch.
And we go and I'm going to say I'm going
to go bigger on this one right now.
I say if Lebron,
if Lebron fucking leads the Cleveland
Cavaliers to the championship tonight,
tonight, tonight, gave seven,
seven, seven, seven years. Um,
in my mind he passed his Coby Brian. All
right, I'm just pausing right now. Oh,
what the fuck everybody's going to
say all that shit. I just feel like a,
the level of leadership
that he would have to show
in order to do that.
You know what I mean?
Compared to the teams that Coby played
on where he had all this fucking help.
You know what I mean?
Cause I feel like Lebron's already done
the Cobi Championship where you piled on
with Shaq and all that fucking shit.
He went down there with Dwayne
Wade and all those guys,
but to go to the middle of fucking
nowhere as far as sports goes and lead a
fucking sad sack,
fucking city said sex city out of,
out of the fucking they're cursed.
Lack of championships is,
is a way bigger accomplishment than
any than any of copis five that he had.
You know,
my big beef with him is he,
if Phil Jackson wasn't the coach and he
didn't have major free agents signings
there, they immediately became a 500 team
with Colby score and 40 points a night.
You know, just being like, well,
I got my stats, you guys suck.
And then he just would walk
off the court. I don't know. I,
I would in my sports mine,
my unathletic comedic sports mind,
I put that with like,
just watching like the Pistons walking
off the court when the fucking bowls
finally beat him.
Those out of was just something fucking
wrong about that walk in off the fucking
court when he fucking share.
Um,
um, did she have a walk off the court
that she walk off a battleship ever when,
when she didn't think the sound was
right? I have no fucking idea. Anyways,
I'm plowing ahead here. Um, had an
amazing fucking time. I did a Newark,
New Jersey, um, performance ad,
Santa, whatever the hell they called.
They had some great shows.
And then last night I played
this some fucking place in, um,
I don't know why. I don't know the
names on this run. Um, hang on a second.
Typing in the password.
One fucking word letter at a time.
I played this place last night and it
was the same venue where Mike Tyson
knocked out fucking, uh,
Michael Spinks. Now granted,
you know,
the way they sat it when he had zonked,
I sold the same amount of
tickets, believe me. Um,
they can see it in all these different
ways. So they sat it more for comedy show,
but when he fucking did it, it was like
right now a turtle Gadi fought there.
All these amazing boxing
matches, uh, had had been there.
And if you went in there, man, I
literally felt like I was in citizen Kane.
I got to get you guys in the
name of this fucking place.
One of the more amazing places
I've ever gotten to walk into.
We had this old fucking,
um,
it's old organ there and shit is,
it could still going to be on my website
or not. Ah, for Fuck Sakes, Bill,
Bill, er, ah,
just go build a fucking dope
Phenix city. Let's see. Let's see.
Let's see. There's something
ballroom come and get fence.
You know, you fucking cow fucking, it
just disappears. It's unbelievable.
You get kicked in the balls at
fucking lives forever on the Internet.
Fucking one goddamn day later. I
can't find it. Whatever. Well, Anik,
I'll tell you, if you ever want to make
a zillion dollars in Atlantic city,
opened up a tattoo removal,
fuck a tattoo removal store,
whatever you called service Jesus Christ.
Those were some of the worst fucking
tattoos I've ever seen in my life.
What the fuck is the name of the venue?
You can't,
this is what I do and
I can't figure it out.
Just start landing city boardwalk hall.
And um,
actually, you know, my, my back has been
way better, but just riding in a car,
I don't know what it is. It just
fucks with my leg. I get this,
the nerve starts acting up again,
but I'm like 85% of the way back.
I'm really psyched. So, um,
I didn't want to deal with driving that
two hour thing down the turnpike. So,
uh,
I actually for once blue,
a little bit of cash and uh,
I took a helicopter ride down from the
fucking west side of Manhattan Down to
Atlantic City was the shit.
I flew on an a star. Um,
I've got to sit up
right next to the pilot.
I didn't get one of the seats in the back,
which was cool.
I bought a ticket and piled on this thing.
Some other people going down
there and I'm so fucking shit man.
He came out like I was always
terrified of being like, Oh man,
I don't know if I would want to fly.
I still wouldn't,
I would never fly around
Manhattan without uh, in its,
cause it's just so much fucking traffic
but you just go out over the Hudson and
just like you're driving down the street,
you just get on the right side.
I couldn't look over and see his gauges
to see what altitude we were flying out.
We went right down the
Hudson River and um,
by the freedom tower and all that stuff.
And then we got to the other side.
Now the other side, we've got
the south side and this, um,
you know the statue of Liberty's
right there, Ellis island,
and then we went right over the Verrazano
Bridge and there's no way to fucking
go over that thing and not think of
fucking Saturday night fever. You know,
when that fucking Guy Bobby,
whatever his fucking name is,
tries to do the head stay looking at
me. I'm like, you guys, I look at me,
they're like, Bobby,
don't fucking do it by me.
And Him and his ball,
he has to suit,
just go all the way down
to the fucking bottom.
Man is fucking fucking unbelieve.
I'm at that fucking scene.
Scared the shit out of me when
I was a kid, but now you know,
just him as his fucking Afro and
just fucking big call. You know,
it's almost like if he went in head first,
he would have been fine or actually
maybe it would absorb too much water and
he'd hit the bottom. I have no idea.
But anyways, when we went over that,
then we went over Red Bank,
New Jersey,
made a right and went right down
the coast. Went by Asbury Park.
So the forking Jersey shore.
And it actually made me think like,
I can't believe I never went to
either one of those places. Um,
went down to Atlantic City and then we,
uh,
had a great time down there and tonight
I'm in Baltimore, so that's basically it.
But a fuck an underrated,
underrated being in Manhattan,
blowing a little bit of cash,
piling onto a fucking helicopter with a
few other fucking passengers get in the
last seat and fucking flying
by that amazing skyline, man.
It was the shit.
And I finally got to
ride in an a star and a,
it was way less intimidating than
he thought it was going to be.
I thought when I looked at the cockpit,
all the gauges and everything branded,
they were analog. I don't like that
digital shit. I fucking hate that stuff.
I don't trust it. I don't like
it. I'm not a technology guy.
I like when everything looks
like a fucking weird clock,
then I feel like I can read it. I don't,
I don't like all that, that type of shit.
So, um, anyway, so many
minutes away up to here,
I would do the advertising and they
just don't know if it's come in yet. Um,
let's see if we got anything.
Nothing. So anyways, as always,
as I've been trying to mention here
so I can support my fellow comics, um,
if you liked this podcast or stuff like
this or maybe you're sick of it and
you'd like to listen to
another one. Uh, we have,
I feel the best collection
of 'em of podcasts on of
any other podcast network at
the all things comedy network. We
got Bert Kreischer, we got, uh,
who else we got? We got a Phillippi
Esparza's what's up fool podcasts?
We've got Aaron Foley's
fucking sports with the balls.
We got Dean del Rey's let,
let there be Doug. Stan.
Hope this is murder is fucking row here.
Bunch of other fucking people on here.
Um,
and it's all just high quality stuff.
Eddie Pepitone, Tom Papa. Come on man.
What else? She going to
get podcasts like this, um,
Tom Gore and your mom's house. We
got all kinds of stuff there. So, uh,
um, let me click on a few of these
here so I can give some shout outs.
Ari Shaffir skeptic tank. Um,
it's a great website and a,
we just got some investors on it,
which is great.
So we're going to start having
some more original content,
which is why I'm trying to
drive some traffic there.
It'd be a good fucking team player.
Okay.
So after I do my show here tonight
and beautiful fucking Baltimore,
Baltimore, um, I'm flying,
this is my fucking day.
I'm flying out to la.
I go right into the writer's
room and after that I'm doing a,
I'm doing a benefit that's really
important to me. Um, great friend of mine,
Bobby Slayton,
unfortunately his wife passed away
a few months ago and we're doing a,
a benefit and memory of her at the Saban
theater and a Beverly hills and uh,
the fucking lineups.
Ridiculous.
Arsenio Hall is hosting and there's a
few other up and coming comics you might
have heard of. Like, I dunno, Ray
Romano, Dana Carvey, Jon Lovitz,
Brian Regan,
Bob Saget,
and I'll be a fucking
pulling up the rear there, a
low man on the totem pole and that
show would definitely be me. Um,
I'm a huge fan of all of those guys,
so I can't believe I'm going
to get to work with them. Um,
unfortunately it's not the greatest
reasons why we're doing it, but um,
we love Bobby and um, it's a great
benefit. There are a few tickets left.
It's going to be a crazy show and I have
a feeling all those guys are going to
be fucking with each other cause they
known each other for so long and a,
I want to be like beyond a fan
boy that night. And then, uh,
then after that I go home and then
I go right on a fucking plane.
I have to go back to New York because a
got to work with some actors to do some
voiceovers. We're up to episode eight.
Everybody. No recording episodes. Seven.
Huh?
Dog Days of summer.
We'll come around but coming
around so fucking psyched.
We're up to episode seven. We're going to
do the table reef episode, April accord,
the table, uh, the fucking episode. Um,
uh, next week. Hey, you know, I just
realized, you know, be cool if there's,
if one of you guys out there
want it to come to a table read,
I got to figure out how to do a, uh,
some sort of contest or something.
Maybe bringing in for episode
10, whenever we record that. Uh,
I don't know why the fuck I never
thought to do that. You know, it's funny,
I don't even invite my wife to him.
I'm so busy like pouring over the script,
making sure, you know, I don't fuck up
the jokes at the table read, but um,
you know what, I'm going to
figure out how to do that and I'm,
I'm promising you right now, by next
Thursday. Yeah, Thursday podcast.
We'll have something set up for that.
I think that'd be a really cool,
if you're into the show, if you're not
into the show, then you probably be like,
well, hey bill, maybe I just want to go
get a fucking cheese stick or some shit.
Cheese, steak, sorry. Anyways, let me, uh,
what else do I want to talk about here?
This is usually where I do
the fucking advertising. I
guess I can't this week. Um,
okay.
Oh,
formula one racing,
how the European Grand Prix over there.
Um,
I actually didn't get a chance to watch
that because I stayed out too late,
but I did tape it. But
spoiler alert, spoiler alert,
a Nico Rosberg fucking Nico,
Nico Rosberg, he won his fifth fucking
race, right? One, two, three, four, five.
He's won five of them. He's
the points leader. He's a,
he's with the German team.
Okay.
And he's just funny. Ross
Park, you know what I mean?
It's about time they fucking made up
for it. Had a Jewish guy drive for them,
you know, um, I don't even know
if he's Jewish or anything,
but he also drives from Mercedes.
So I always root for Germany
and Mercedes because, uh,
I've never done a background check, but
I think I'm mostly German just based on,
uh, what my parents have told me. Um,
but oh my God,
I saw the pictures of it too,
just driving through this
beautiful fucking city.
I don't know where the fuck I been for
so goddamn long when it comes to Formula
One. Now of course me, cause I'm a psycho.
Somebody told me about the fucking,
you know, the basically the former
formula one of motorcycle racing. Um,
I don't know why I'm not watching that.
I sit there and I flip out where I love
all these fucking crazy contact sports.
Right. You know, I like
rugby, Australian rules,
football and this fucking Mad Max shift
that people been showing me lately where
it's sort of rugby sort of soccer and
after somebody scores you can punch him in
the face. I don't know what the
fuck that is. It's like football,
soccer, rugby in bullying all
at the same fucking time, man.
It's just, I dunno about
that. Sports you don't,
you don't think it was missing was just
to have a couple of bowls run in there
and just start fucking trampling people.
Um,
okay.
But anyways, uh, let me
shut this fucking TV off.
This is really fucking with my brain here.
Um,
I don't know why if I liked
all that type of shit.
Why watching somebody ride a
motorcycle 200 fucking miles an hour.
Um, it's absolutely, and you know,
it is amazing to me is these guys
are so good that when they go down,
they don't die somehow. You think they,
I mean, not saying people don't die,
but you'd think they would die every
fucking time. You know what I mean?
Okay.
The fact that you can wear a fucking suit
that is so God damn strong,
you to go 200 miles an hour and you could
fall off your fucking bike and it just
doesn't like what should happen there
is like after fucking two seconds of
skidding on the asphalt at 200 miles
an hour immediately you should just see
guy's ass. His bear has, should be there.
And then you just see it looks like steak
and then it would look like bones and
then that would just be it
and the guy would be dead.
You would think that that
would happen every time.
And these fucking guys just slide in
these goddamn soaps there were incredible.
Not saying people don't
die. But um, I think, um,
I think this is sort of my next thing
man. Cause like, you know what's funny,
this time of year when hockey ends and
basketball ends, everybody a football fan,
you know, Pixie the hockey or
hoop for the most part. All right,
very few go hockey and
then wait and go baseball.
I only know a couple guys like that. So
people go hockey or fucking hoop and um,
people who watch hockey don't
watch who people watch hoop,
don't fucking watch hockey. They have
nothing in common with each other.
And the only thing that they have in
common with each other other than their
love of football is the sheer fucking
panic of the day after the game.
Seven or your final or your finals when
that's over and you're like, holy fuck,
what am I going to do now for the next
two and a half fucking months is I wait
for the NFL regular season to start.
And I'm not shitting on
baseball cause I love baseball.
I just that that the fucking dog
days of summer, I can't stand like,
you know who the fuck wants
to go out to the ballpark?
It's like fucking a hundred degrees
out. You know, who does die hearts,
I guess I'm not a die hard baseball fan,
but I love it. I love it in uh, October.
So I needed a sport and Formula One dude,
I'm telling you like the race today was,
it was only like something
like 50 something laps.
You can really just sit down and they bang
it out in a couple of hours. You know,
you get to learn about other
fucking cities, you know,
half of them they go to you like,
oh shit, I'd like to go there.
It all those people hanging out,
calling it right now.
At some point I'm going to hit a fucking
country when they have a formula one
race is actually one here.
It says,
the United States says United States
Grand Prix for the life of me,
I think it's an Austin,
Texas,
which is really disappointing to me that
that's where they're going to fucking
have it. You know what I mean? Why
the fuck is it in Austin, Texas?
They should have that
thing in like Chicago,
Chicago should have a
Formula One fucking race.
That's a cool ass fucking city,
you know,
fucking zipping over the rivers at
one point. Only one car could make it,
they'd probably kill each other.
Um,
I don't even know what the track
looks like in Austin, but um,
all I know is Austin is a great city.
Once you're in it,
trying to get to it with that fucking
traffic is an absolute God damn nightmare.
So, um, anyways, I guess this is a
place here where I would actually pause,
right? And I would do some
sort of advertising. Um,
I'm just going to say this so
I can edit it in later. Uh,
we're going to pause here right now.
The little bit of that advertising,
where the fuck is my reads?
Come on,
give me the reeds gave me the reeds. Ah,
you can't. All right. But you know what?
It doesn't matter you guys because this
is not going to be in real time for
yourself. Oh my God. Is this podcast suck?
As bad as it sounds in my fucking
head right now. Um, you know,
is going to say about Baltimore. Every
time I go to the Baltic, Baltimore,
the Baltimore, I always think about
the wire and I was going to go,
I remember the wire and then I was going
to go boop, boop, boop, boop, boop,
which is for Lauren order. I can't even
remember how the fucking song went.
I just remember the song in the end,
the guy was screaming
up and as you can tell,
I'm kind of losing my fucking voice with
the voiceover shit and screaming about
my deck here on stage. Um, but
you know what I'm psyched about.
He's my fucking act as coming together
and I'm getting ready to do another
special,
I think I'm going to do it in October
and all I gotta do is just get through
these last three fucking episodes.
Okay.
Give 100% on that shit and then that's it.
Then all of a sudden it's,
it's old Billy fucking flank
steak. Remember when I said
I wasn't going to drink?
You know, I fucked up on
Thursday, Friday and Saturday.
Okay. But I was great Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday, and Sunday, right.
So when I get back, I'm going
back to not drink it. I gotta,
I gotta get back off this, but I just, I
dunno what happened, you know, I fucking,
uh, I don't want to happen. You
know what I mean? What happened?
I went on the fucking road.
That's what happened.
And I went to New York and I met up
with some fucking friends and like, Hey,
let's go to this fucking
bar. And then, you know, it's
like one of these wine bars,
you know, so you don't feel like you're
drinking. So I showed up, you know,
another buddy of mine, it's fucking
comic. I'm not going to say,
I don't want to name any names,
but this guy's fucking hilarious.
And he comes in and it was hilly verse,
he called him out.
He just goes like, cause he showed
up and uh, I know what you're saying,
but why did you go to a wine bar?
Because there were ladies there and
that's what they fucking picked, right?
So like,
I will fucking go there.
So he shows up and I immediately go,
dude,
it's a wine bar. I don't, cause
he wanted a beer and a shot and I,
his face fucking dropped in first.
He called out,
he goes through the level of
fucking disappointment on your face.
And then we find out that they
had beer and they did have a shot,
but it was just, you know, this foofy
place. So the dude goes, uh, they go,
can't get some drink. He goes, yeah,
can I just get a, a, a bud light?
And the guy's like, ah,
yeah, no, we don't, we don't
have bud light. Uh, we have,
we have a blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, whatever the fuck it is,
some Italian beer. And he goes,
guys, like, Oh, what? And he's like,
have a Bob on the ball, but he
just goes, is, is, is that a beer?
And the guy goes, yeah. And he goes, all
right, I'll have one of those. And, uh,
I don't know what happened.
And we started doing Tequila
shots in the whole fucking thing.
Went off the rails, and I'm a fat fuck.
And I all like myself right now there.
I said it a fucking in a hotel, Roman
Baltimore eating French fries in bed.
Huh? Like some fucking, I don't know,
somebody whose dreams didn't come true.
That's who we just,
French fries in bed or maybe people who
fucking everything worked out for him
and then just so fucking bored.
They, you know, like Marlon Brando,
whatever the fuck his issue was. Oh,
I've won every award that exists.
Bring me a fucking elk.
Said he just sat in bed just non on the
fucking antlers for like 10 years and
all of a sudden, you know,
he's ready to do the fucking,
what is it? What the fuck? Gorilla
monsoon movie. I have bio pic. I have no,
I don't know how those things work.
I don't pretend to fucking know. Um,
so anyways,
we're going to pause here for a
little bit of advertising the floor.
We come back with a
Monday morning podcast.
Okay. And we're back.
Um, so I figured, forget,
I'll take me a good fucking three
minutes to read those constantly.
Maybe five minutes or whatever. Send me
is I can get to the, I can get to the, uh,
the questions right now. Can I, I think
I can't, don't get too close to them.
Like bill second, you fucking s exhale.
It all goes off the fucking rails.
Um, all right, here we go.
All right, advice first. You know,
some kind of fucking Ireland,
some cutting island gave me
shit about the ticket prices.
I think that's a little bit too much. I
think you're funny. It's like, hey dude,
how about the fact I'm flying from
the other side of the fucking world?
Almost Santee your fucking doorstep.
That's not enough for you.
Who's going to pay for all that fuel?
Um, all right, here we go. Advice for,
for a daft Scotsman. Hey
there, you're redheaded con.
Uh,
I cannot fucking wait to go back to
Scotland are lit and all these fucking
places,
these miserable conscious,
some of the funniest people you'll
ever going to meet. All right. He says,
I'm 26 year old guy from near Glasgow,
Scotland.
Um,
for quite a while I was in a bit of a Rut,
but eventually I managed to pick myself
out of it and decided to do something
that I've always wanted to do.
I took a big step and decided to buy
a ticket to a festival in Chicago.
I was the Shit I love Chicago,
said I booked my flights and I'll be in
the city for a week. That's tremendous.
So basically my question is as I'll be
traveling alone and we'll be staying
alone,
how easy is it to just hang around and
strike up conversations with complete
strangers in a different country?
Have you ever found difficulties in
finding common ground in conversation with
people from different countries?
Also,
any full pause I should avoid when talking
to Americans so I can prevent getting
my cunt kicked in. All the
best you fat shaming, Prick.
Um, all right. So a lot
of questions there. Um,
yeah,
well the only time I ever traveled
is when I, I, I'm doing stand up.
And then after the show there's always
people that just saw you do a show.
So I've already broken the ice.
But, um, first things first,
why don't I tell you a couple of places
to go to from my little fucking places
to go, thing that I have in my fucking
phone that my wife used to make fun of.
She made fun and places to go and she
was laughing and then, you know what?
We went to one of those fucking places
and then all of sudden, you know,
she's just, she has total faith in it
now she tells me, hit it. All right,
here's what I would go.
All right if you like a nice fucking a
great fucking bar for music and that type
of thing, I'd go to the Liar's club. Um,
if you like cigars is a place,
big cigar pouring them,
check that fucking place up.
And then as far as food and all that shit,
I would just tweet about it because
a, I'm not a big fan of, of,
of deep dish pizza. You know what
I mean? I just don't understand it.
I don't understand deep dish patient
pizza the way I don't understand why white
coffee and tea have to be so fucking hot.
You know what I mean?
I went, so it gets to the fucking,
the tea bag all in the water maybe.
Is that what the fuck it is?
I just don't understand.
But you have to wait like an hour before
you can drink it without scalding your
fucking mouth. And when it comes to
deep dish pizza, it's, it's just,
it's just too fucking much,
you know?
And he can't just get a slice of it that
they bring the fucking thing over. It's,
it's like, hey, you want
some lasagna? Yeah, but not a
whole fucking tray, you know?
Um,
but you should definitely try it.
If you get one that actually has a
really good crust, it is pretty amazing.
But it's just like, I mean,
you can literally split one
piece with somebody else.
It's so fucking big. And, uh, my
wife said the funniest shit about it.
She called it an abomination.
She goes,
it's the ultimate expression
of American gluttony. She goes,
go to Italy, you won't see anything,
anything over there like it.
And it's true. But we went to
Italy, you know, they have like,
we have all our American versions of
their dishes, you know what I mean?
But there's no deep dip, deep,
deep dish pizza in Italy,
at least not in any place.
We went to enrollment.
It's the only place I've been to. But you
don't see it. Uh, that's what she said.
And she goes, you know why? Because
it's an abomination. Um, so anyways, uh,
as far as I found in that,
that Liar's club, uh, people
were fucking cool as hell.
If you're into the music and
shit, it's a good time. But Dude,
you're going to be coming
over with the fucking accent.
I wouldn't go to the fucking,
you know, I, you know,
it depends on what you
went to. I would go to, uh,
a place where this going to
be a bunch of beautiful women.
That's what I would do it. And then you
go over there and he just fucking, just,
just start talking and I think you'll
be in the fucking game and there'll be,
who'd you come over here with?
Vr Guy came over by myself.
I want to always wanted to come
to Chicago and just literally,
you know how hall watching,
what do you fucking Berge do?
Whatever the of a fuck you guys talk,
right?
Who the fuck you fuck you
do over here for fun? Yes.
Garrett wearing could write whatever the
fuck you going to say and they're going
to love it. They're going to love it.
Even if you ask him, hey for fucking Shag,
any however the fuck you say
fucking and your country,
it's going to seem so cool.
Them, it's so different.
And then also they're going to be
more adventurous because you know,
you're the stories leaving
with you when you go back,
when you fly back to Scotland.
Um,
how can you avoid getting
your head kicked in? Um,
don't do what everybody else from other
countries do is you come here and you
criticize the United States
and talk about how dumb we are,
how fat we are, how awful the
foreign policy is, how uh,
our football players are
pussies cause they wear pads.
Why do you call it football? All of
that dumb shit. You know what I mean?
It's so fucking obnoxious,
you know?
You know why it's obnoxious because they,
those kinds of people always come
here and they act like these.
There are these worldly
traveled people, you know, oh,
I come from here and I come from there
and we can do this and we can do that.
And it's just like, well, in
all of that fucking travel,
you never learned to be on
your best behavior when he
come to somebody's country
and you don't come in and insulted.
So you make your whole country look
like a bunch of fucking snobby cons.
You never learned that one.
I am.
I'm on my best fucking behavior
when I go to a different country.
I'm not saying I'll go out
and get fucking hammered,
but like I don't go there and shit on it.
You know,
some of these places I go to,
I'm fucking talking to people.
I know this place is nice. There was
that. Why the fuck did you come here?
We, I was looking, I was in
Oslo, Norway. I said, you know,
you guys were, thanks. Slide you guys,
but great. I'll definitely be back.
It's somebody yelled out why?
It just struck. I was like, why?
What do you mean? Why? Why the fuck
wouldn't I, it's fucking beautiful.
I don't know. Anyway, so I
would avoid doing that. Um,
and then just everything else is common
sense. You know, somebody, you know,
looking like a psycho, just fucking leave
him alone. But I don't know dude. I,
I mean I judge a lot of
Scotland on that movie.
Trainspotting or I just feel like I don't
go into any bars with is an upper deck
to it. Cause I just feel
like there's going to be that
guy up there that's going,
just finish his fucking pint,
just throw the glass over his head,
cut open some woman's face.
Like I just, you know,
if it's even remotely
like that over there,
I think you're going to
be fine in Chicago. Um,
I would definitely try to go to a cubs
game. Uh, no offense to white sox fans,
but you know, you guys all know that
you fucking stadium stinks. You know,
it stinks. It's the only time I ever
saw a stadium, a new stadium built,
and they admitted so quickly like, wow,
we really fucked this up. Let's try it.
Like it was like a botch nose job. You
know what I mean? Like your stadium is,
is the fucking stadium version of like,
you know,
when some Hollywood chick or somebody,
they get too much work done on their face
and people, oh my God, what happened?
That's what you did do with that
stadium. They're like, well,
let's wait till it settles. Let's see
what happens. You know? All right,
so there you go. But Dude, you
picked a great fucking city to go to.
Chicago is the shit and then you picked
a great time of the year to go there. Um,
I will tell you the traffic is fucking
horrific, so just get ready for that.
But once you're in it, it's
fucking phenomenal. Um, all right,
what do we go here? All
right, uh, dear Billy,
stretchy pants on your
podcast sometime back,
you were talking about someone getting
with someone else and one of the people
gaining a bunch of weight. Oh yeah.
When you start dating somebody,
how it's not fair to the other person
for you to then put on a bunch of fucking
weight. Um, unless you're a woman, you
having a baby that's obviously, you know,
I'm not a fucking animal here,
but I'm just saying, you know,
after you have the kid, you know,
that's, that's when you know,
after your wife has a kid too, things
should happen. This is what you do.
You get a little bassinet
for the beautiful baby and
then the second thing you
do is you get an elliptical for your wife,
but so she doesn't get mad at you.
What you do is you get her initials
engraved on the side of it in plastic.
Of course. Totally kidding. All right. Um,
I was already a few weeks into whipping
myself back into shape. Uh, okay.
Let me just start this over again cause
I've even forgot what the fuck he's
talking about.
On Your podcast sometimes
back you sometime back you
were talking about someone
getting with someone else and one of
the people gaining a bunch of weight.
I was already a few weeks into
whipping myself back into shape,
but this really helped me solidify my
will. Well, that's fucking great, man.
It's great.
I wish she can you help me because I,
you know what's sitting in a
fucking writer's room is like,
I eat there like the way I
eat on the road. I mean, I,
it's just fucking hard to try to eat
healthy. It's just, you're just bored.
You're freaking out. You're locked in
the fucking room and you're like, oh,
I'm going to eat some
fucking candy for no reason.
I'm sitting there everyday like, it's
Halloween and I'm fucking seven years old.
I got to stop.
All right.
It made me think that I should really
give my lady the respect of maintaining
something close to the body I had when
she got on this train. Uh, she loves me.
She stayed with me in spite of the
lumpy beanbag chair I have become,
and now I'm 15 pounds down
with a bunch more to go,
but I am back on my routine.
Four or five trips to the gym
at five 30 in the morning. Dude,
you're fucking killing it. That's
great. And Calorie counting as well.
I know exactly what to do. It's just
the time. Now my question is this,
how do you deal with it if you're lady
wants you to eat the same stuff she is or
wants to go to a shitty fried food
restaurant. Anyways, thanks man.
Hope season two of F is for family is
coming along. Well. It is. Thank you sir.
Can't wait to see it. And I loved
your last show in Austin. Hurry back.
Can come during the football season.
We had a monster fucking recruiting
class this year. Thanks you bastard.
Oh that's great man. You
could, longhorn should be good.
So the legendary a college program
there. All right. Um, all right.
How do you deal with, I would just say
I want to just, that's easy as easy.
Just sit down with her and
just say, hey listen, you know,
when you got with me,
I was however years old and I w I weighed
this much and I don't think it's fair
for me to have put on all
this fucking weight, you know?
And they'd be looking like a lumpy
beanbag chair, like you said.
So I'm really trying to get myself
back into shape. So I was wondering if,
you know, you know, if you want to eat
something that's a little, uh, unhealthy,
is there any way we just can go to a
place that has healthy options for me?
All right.
Because a,
I don't want to look bad for you
and I also don't want to die early,
so you're fucking,
you know,
in your forties and 50s having to put
lipstick on and get the fuck back out
there again and try to meet somebody
who works down at Sears, you know?
And I don't,
I don't want to do that to you.
I'd like to be here for the long haul
there. There's no fucking way she,
she'll give you shit about that, that,
that's a very easy thing to have happen,
you know? And then also, I think,
sorry, I'm looking at the timer.
I also think that she would
be happy to hear that you,
you weren't just doing this
for some vein reason yourself,
that you would actually
also doing it for her.
I think that that would be pretty
cool. Now, watch now watch.
He'll fucking getting some big
fucking fight. You know, I,
you think the thing I eat bad.
She say I'm fat.
You know, she blows her sales manager.
All right. Read this. Okay. All right.
I'm going to read this.
Relax. Uh, what's up dickhead?
Let's go fucking bro and
can't wait for next season.
I just moved to wildly
mediocre Los Angeles.
Uh,
well yeah,
that's what you're going to feel like
cause you just fucking move there. Um,
but if you stay open minded,
which is really difficult
for east coast people to do.
I did that the first time I came to la.
I went to La and I tried to do Boston
New York Shit. And then when I couldn't,
I was like, oh, there's police spoken.
Sucks. It doesn't, it's fucking amazing.
Beautiful women.
Some of the best food you ever going
to have so much outdoor activity.
Just fucking embrace it.
Stop trying to be the fucking Boston guy.
You're not on a reality shelf. All right.
Take it down a few fucking notches.
Nobody gives a fuck in Los Angeles that
you don't like it. Everybody just thinks,
well then go back to fucking Boston.
Go back to Philly.
Wherever the fuck you're from.
If it's so fucking great.
Why did you accept a job
out here? All right, sorry,
I'm just heading you off for
the past before you come.
Another cont shitting on fucking la and
he said I worked for the UFC editing
fight highlights.
Uh,
thanks for keeping me entertained
with your semi literate babble babble.
Bullshit. Day after day. This is
like a classic East Coast Guy.
He really likes me and likes what I,
what I do,
but he just can't get himself to say
it cause his dad never hugged him.
So I'm not taking any of
this personally anyway.
My girlfriend is about to
move here to meet me. Uh,
she had to stay behind when I
moved because she's a teacher.
Needed to finish out the school
year. Uh, we get along great.
I trust her and she treats me
better than I deserve. However,
sometimes I can't take how
ditzy she can be. Uh, uh,
starting to pull some threads.
Here she is successful and very book
smart but sometimes lacks common sense.
I find feeling embarrassed when she says
some stupid shit in front of my friends
or parents. It's kind of a hard
thing to discuss with her though.
You know what Shit, what
the fuck should I do? Also,
I'm coming to your show at
the same theater this Monday.
I'm looking forward to it,
so don't blow it.
Well I appreciate you coming out to
that. Like I said, it was, you know,
a really good friend of mine
and for a great cause. Uh,
so thank you for doing that.
All right,
well here's the deal dude.
You either have to accept the fact that
she can be a little ditsy or you have to
come to the realization that you're dating
a fucking dope and you got to get rid
of her. It's one of the other, um,
I mean, look, she doesn't sound
like she's 100% that I've dated.
People like that that were a little,
you know,
they were either locked in
or just sort of floating.
It was really weird and they
could say really like amazing.
Like spot on shit.
And then two minutes later could just
could say something like, oh my God,
what the fuck was that?
Um,
but I have to tell you that's kind of a,
that's kind of a big deal. They'll do,
you know, you can't think that the
person you're dating is a dope, you know,
you get into that situation and uh,
I dunno,
you start thinking about getting married,
you start thinking about having kids.
You're like,
is my kid going to be half a dope or a
full on dope is used as a kid going to
get all of that DNA from her?
Who the fuck knows I'm all right.
It's kind of hard to think to
discuss with her, you know,
what are you gonna say to her? Can you
stop saying Dumb Shit? I mean, this,
there's no way to do that, you
know, I'm trying to think of,
that's like my wife telling me to work on
my team. I mean, I do work on my temper,
but I mean, it's Kinda
how I made up. I mean,
if somebody ditzy, they're fucking ditzy.
That would be like my wife telling me,
okay, can you be a little less
pasty? It's like, ah, I can,
I can become red for a few days
as well.
That's about the best I could do. I don't
know what else you want from me, but uh,
you know, I think you,
uh, need to maybe move on.
I'm not saying you need to move on. Yeah.
You either accept this about her or ego.
You got to walk one of the Yoga.
Um, all right, here's another one.
Jesus Christ can't come and
I don't mean to the wedding.
Um, how's it going, Billy? Butterballs
uh, if you're reading this on Monday,
it's fucking sick.
June 20th will is my 21st birthday.
Oh,
Jesus. I don't know what's going on here.
Great gift hearing you read this. Uh,
well you're not going to hear it until
the fucking Monday anyways. All right.
I'm mealling mealling I'm
emailing today though,
is I was with this girl last
summer, some good sex, no big deal,
but we didn't have anything going on
during the year when we were at college.
Well, we're back at it this summer,
but the thing is I can't come.
I mean, I'm doing good. Pretty
good. Uh, p p m pumps per,
but I just can't finish now.
I know you're not a doctor,
so not going to ask you why,
but how should I go about this?
I think she's getting self conscious,
but she's a hard eight and I'm a soft six.
She's hot. It's not a
fault. Daddy can finish.
Daddy can't finish when the pressure
is on. How should I be playing this?
I can only laugh it off for so long.
I'll try not jerking off to,
maybe that'll help. Any advice.
Thanks for the read, man.
Oldfield be able to come check you
out when you come back. East Coast,
maybe Baltimore and Sunday. Go sox. Go
Fuck Yourself. Uh, yeah. I, you know,
don't rub one out. If you're watching
too much porn, maybe that's a problem.
Or maybe, you know, you don't want
to be in a relationship with her.
And that's the weird way your body's
reacting. Like you're wasting time. Um,
so we're not going to fuck it.
I don't know if there's a
billion psychological go
reasons, but yeah, I, yeah,
just don't rub one out for awhile.
You know, this is another thing too.
Women are fucking, they're very
forgiving people. If I would,
I wouldn't laugh it off. I would talk
to her about it and just say, listen,
obviously this is happening.
It's bothering me. Um,
I'm feeling pressure about it and I'm
also feeling like in a round about,
I just don't want you to be taken my issue
on like, this something you are doing,
you're not doing anything wrong.
There's something going on with me.
And then she'll be like, well, maybe
you should go talk to somebody about it.
And because you're a fucking red sox fan,
I'm assuming you're from the Boston area,
you don't want to go to therapy.
And even if you do go to therapy,
it's not going to help because you
probably have enough Irish blood in you.
And they always said,
who is that fucking psychologist that
said the Irish are like immune to therapy.
Um, I dunno if you liked
this girl, I would definitely
talk to her about it. But,
uh, there's no reason to put any pressure
on yourself, you know what I mean?
Just don't rub one out. Don't
watch any porn. Just a, you know,
I dunno.
Just let it back up.
I don't fucking know. I'm not a doctor.
Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ started.
Here we go. Here we go. Winded down.
Wind it down. All right. Heroin. Um,
I have no family, no friends. I work
in support myself. I have no kids,
no relationship. I actually enjoy
freedom and being alone to an extent.
I'm in my twenties. I had a lot of sex
relationships and ended up getting herpes.
Slash.
HPV.
I would basically rather just not tell
people and not have relationships than to
have. Then they have to
have 35 years old. Uh,
didn't have to at 35 years old.
Deal with having to explain
slash tell this to women.
I really like heroin. Uh, what the
fuck? Jesus Christ. Buddy, what are you,
what are we doing here is, this doesn't
sound real. I really like heroin.
I go to work, come home and use heroin
on a daily basis. I still pay my bills.
I still work,
but I've traded the pleasure of sex
slash having a family slash relationships
for that,
of watching TV shows slash movies
while high on falling asleep,
then going to work the next day.
Should I change this?
Okay.
Is this a, I'll try it. You know
what, I'll, I'll treat it as real. Um,
should I listen to society,
stop using,
go out there and find women and tell
them about my situation and hope they do
not reject me and get
clean or if I am happy,
is it okay for me to just accept
the women part of my life is over,
eat whatever I want,
use whatever drug I want and fill the
time I have left on this planet watching
shows, movies, playing games,
and resigning myself to the fact that
I will be alone. Love the podcast.
Heroine gets a bad rap.
It may sound crazy,
but people can use opiates and still be
responsible. I know many people who do,
it's like alcohol. Both can be
physically. This is really fascinating.
Um, uh, or for, maybe it's a
big lie. I Dunno. It's alcohol.
It's like alcohol.
Both can be physically addictive.
Alcohol can actually kill
you with withdrawals.
Why heroin cannot.
And the deaths you hear about
heroin are from idiots overdosing.
Um, if we, well, what if you get
a bad batch and that something,
you know it's too fucking
strong. Um, I dunno.
I don't pretend to know.
All right.
If we reported all the deaths from
alcohol involved incidents, they're easy.
Well they do report all of them.
As far as I know,
it's like they're trying to hide them.
They are easily 100 times more
than heroin related deaths.
But in our society right now,
opiates are not acceptable because too
many white middle class parents are
finding their idiot kids using them
without understanding tolerance slash
okay.
Proper dosing anyways,
love the podcasts.
I'm not leaving any contact info so I
have no way to know if you read this,
just thought it might be an interesting
subject for your show. It is interesting.
Um,
okay.
Yeah, dude, I don't pretend to
know anything about opiates.
All I do know is that the,
um,
I know alcohol can ruin your life,
but I don't think it's nearly
as addicting as heroin.
I actually have heard
that people can fucking,
yeah,
I don't know. But I think, I think
if, if, if what you're saying is true,
I think you're a rare person that can
handle that. I have no idea. Oh fuck.
Now I got to look some shit up.
The last thing I wanted to do
and I got to get going here.
I got my fucking show here
and a half hour, uh oh.
The live reads or hear
the live reads are here.
I guess I'll read them here then. Let me
just see something. Let me just look up.
What do I look up
productive while on heroin,
heroin and employment. Independent
drug morrow. Let's see.
Productivity and heroin addiction.
Okay.
What is this?
How heroin addicts in Vietnam.
Productivity. Heroin Addiction. How
living in a cave turned me into a blogger.
Yeah.
I failed my new year's resolution.
I wish I could do better.
I just don't have enough willpower.
Have you ever set a goal?
You didn't achieve ever tried to new
year's resolution that didn't stick.
What separates the 0.5% from the 99
and a half percent? What makes someone,
some people succeed in building
new sustainable habits,
but almost everyone else fails.
How living in a cave term,
where the fuck's the heroin shit.
How heroin addicts and Vietnam and
your productivity habits are the same.
What everyone knows the horrible
effects of heroin addiction.
Once someone starts taking herring,
it's almost impossible to quit and those
who form a recurring habit will likely
never quit.
So why didn't heroin using Vietnam vets
relapsed when they returned to the USA.
A study from the Washington
school medical over medicine,
very few heroin use in
Vietnam, uh, veteran relapses.
Uh, what very few heroin
using veteran relapsed.
I relapsed when they returned to the USA
and those who did were more likely to
have been illicit drug users
before ever arriving in Vietnam.
These vets weren't addicted
to the chemicals in heroin.
They were addicted to
the experience of Howard.
In a specific situational
context and the same vein,
you think you are in control of what
you do. You think that when you fail,
it's a failure of your willpower.
But the fact is you don't even realize
the influence of the environment has on
you. Did you know that obesity
spreads through a network of friends?
Happiness also spreads
throughout a social network.
You situation determines
your choices as much as,
or more than your own personal choices.
When willpower.
Okay.
So how can I use this to improve
my habit? Oh, it's Jesus Christ.
Join a Wally ball league. I don't even
know what the fuck that was. All right,
let me, let me look up. Let me just
read these fucking things here. Um,
you know what I might read up on
that. I probably won't. I'll try to,
I would never tell people
to fucking, yeah, well, hey,
it's just heroin. You know,
that seems a little crazy to me. Um,
and people always come in an alcoholic.
It's like the fucking pot smokers always
doing that shit. We alcohol actually,
man, there's no medicinal purposes to
fucking, I get it. I get it. But you know,
you guys are also, you know, your pie
in the sky fucking thing with weed.
Like it's like there's the key.
Can't get addicted to weed is another
fucking thing. Jesus Christ. Okay. Yeah.
You just really like it. That's all
you know. All right. You're unique. Oh,
this is helix hallux.
You're unique.
You don't walk like everyone else
talk like everyone else is asleep like
everyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because it truly customized mattress
will cost you five to 10,000 bucks until
now.
Go to Hallux.
He looks sleek.com answer a few simple
questions and they'll run a three d bio,
chem,
bio something or other model of your body
through the proprietary algorithms they
develop with the help of the world's
leading Aragon. Mix it by only
learning experts. The result,
the most comfortable mattress
you've ever slept on.
Alex customers report at 30% improvement
in overall sleep quality and for
couples they customize each side of
the mattress. Your mattress arrives.
I just pictured somebody having one like
the husband so he could bang a woman
while his wife's sleeping
and she would know, you know,
rather than than doing the red wine tests.
But one guy jumps up and down while the
red wine just sits there. Um, you know,
what about mattresses for those people?
Helix customers report at 30% improvement
in overall sleep quality and for cuffs
co couples,
they customize each side of the mattress.
Your mattress arrives at your door in
about a week and shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine to
Forbes are all talking about he leaks.
Sleep. You have 100 nights to try
it out. And if you don't love it,
they pick it up for free and give
you 100% refund. No questions asked.
Gross. What do they do with
that mattress? Go to helix,
sleep.com/burn and get a $50 $50
off your order. That's helic.
sleep.com/burr he likes sleep.com/bar Oh,
here we go. But boop, boop me undies.
Biondi sleeping on a dirty mattress.
But it would do to me undies.
Biondi as cause you got a flat ass.
But when you put me undies around,
you flat as they cut your fucking balls
and you take to get some me undies.
Everybody needs him. Muslims, Christians,
and Jews. Oh yeah. All right. Me undies.
Whenever you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours
a day and your underwear.
But instead of making a statement
like Superman's tight under tights,
under his clothes every day,
your underwear is probably boring me
undies is here to change that. All right?
Every pair of me undies is made
by sustainable source modal,
modal fabric that's
twice as soft as cotton.
Nothing can describe the fit and feel
of me undies, but once you try them on,
your balls will never go back.
And you'll understand why they're called
the world's most comfortable underwear.
And if you don't love your first
pair of me undies, they're free.
No questions asked.
Well,
I'm glad you don't take them back like
the fucking mattress store me undies has
dozens of styles and limited
edition prints to make you
make us to help you make
a statement with your underwear,
whether anyone could see them or not.
Remember Superman.
All right?
Shipping is free in the United States
and Canada and you can save up to eight
bucks. Prepare at me, me, me undies with
with the me Andy's subscription plan.
Get the subscription or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order when
you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] that's [inaudible]
dot com slash burr.
Hey you and he's dot com
slash. Bird. All right. Lastly,
but certainly not leastly
is a dollar shave club.
Everybody dial if I can
shave club kit, uh, guys,
uh,
dollar shave club.
Really appreciate you listening to these
advertisements on this show and they
wanted to thank you. All right. Um,
what have they done
here@dollarshaveclub.com
they arranged for them to,
uh,
what
give new members a month of the executive
razor for free just for buying a tube
of Dr Carver's Shave Butter,
Aka Dr cabbies.
Easy shape butter.
Um,
they're super excited for you to try this.
All right,
now let me remind you why
millions of others have joined.
Okay.
Prayers,
proud members of the club.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing
razors right to your front door for third
of the price of what the greasy, greedy,
crazy, greedy razor corporations charge.
That means when you
joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a
fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic.
All right.
Get a first class shave when you use
the executive blade and that's without
hurting your wallet. All right. And
then after you get the executive Blaine,
he used a little doctor cavities,
easy shave butter,
and the blade just gently glides across
your smooth surface something or other,
whatever. Shea butter isn't
your average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula.
The high quality natural
ingredients ingredients.
Leave your skin feeling
unbelievably soft and smooth.
It's soft as a horse with muzzle now's
a great time to join dollar Shave Club
vacation. Did no new members who buy a
tube of doctor cabbies. Easy shave butter.
Get a month.
Yeah,
of the executive razor for free. He, uh,
take advantage of this
special offer today.
It's available by going to dollar
shave club.com/burr that's dollar shave
club.com/ [inaudible] all right, that's
the podcast for this week. I apologize.
It's a little bit short, but I'm
kind of short on time. All right.
If you'd like to donate to this podcast,
a great way to do it.
Next time you go to amazon.com,
just go to bill bird.com.
You Click on the podcast page,
click on the Amazon link, and a,
it'll take you right to Amazon,
doesn't cost you any more money,
and they kicked me a couple of bucks
for driving traffic their way. Uh,
once again, as always, have a
great week. You fucking cunts.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll talk to you.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.